you're looking at Miami Florida home of
the Miami Dolphins and the site of next
year's Super Bowl now only on CBS this
morning we are seeing firsthand how
staff at major sports arenas are
learning how to save lives
Jamie wax went behind the scenes at Hard
Rock Stadium to find out how employees
are being trained to use trauma kits
after a major accident or attack this is
our trauma bandage all right it's pretty
straightforward this may be the locker
room with the Miami Dolphins
but these drills we're at about 20
seconds have nothing to do with football
21:22 for two days we watched as Stadium
employees from interns to the CEO
learned how to stop traumatic bleeding
and injury if you can put it on your leg
you can put it on somebody else their
coach was Lieutenant Dan stout a 25 year
law enforcement veteran who now works
for tactical medical solutions pack pack
pack pack pack the Dolphins hired the
company to install multiple public
access trauma kits throughout Hard Rock
Stadium and trained its workers on how
to use them it's far more than a
first-aid kit right that's correct these
are stocked with the same equipment that
we give to our military the same
equipment that we give to our first
responders this kit is for very serious
critical stuff whether it's an attack on
an arena in England
or a high school just half an hour from
here
stout told us first responders arrived
at the scene and find civilians coming
to the aid of their neighbors they're
trying to improvise bandages with shirts
they're trying to make tourniquets out
of belts they know what they need what
we're trying to do is provide them with
a basis of training and access to the
right equipment in places where they may
encounter this type of thing how much
difference can it make as far as
survival to have these items close by a
lot of these injuries you've got four to
six minutes to make a difference on
whether that person lives or dies the
kids are packed with step-by-step
instructions and color-coded packaging
which appealed to Dave lassen director
of stadium security do you feel like
your people are safer because of it
absolutely I think anybody can pick this
up and assist which is the end goal is
just to get somebody to a higher echelon
medical care Sidney Williams an event
coordinator with the team says she is
grateful for the extra training
you always know like something like this
could happen really for me I feel a lot
more comfortable knowing that we do have
the appropriate procedures in place so
it makes you feel more safe yes other
stadiums have added similar kits
Gillette Stadium home of the New England
Patriots was the first NFL venue to
install them the New Orleans Saints and
Major League Baseball's New York Yankees
followed for Tom Garfinkel the CEO of
the Miami Dolphins it was an easy
decision we just want to make sure we're
doing everything we can here to make
this the safest environment possible for
our employees and for all of our guests
and everybody that comes and as you say
you take that very personally I do I
want to be able to sleep at night I want
to know that everybody here is safe and
that we've done everything we can to
prevent it from happening and if it does
happen make sure we're responding and
doing everything we can to save lives
the Dolphins organization including
owner Stephen Ross stressed that this
kind of preparedness is important to any
office environment whether the potential
injuries are due to traumatic events or
simply workplace accidents I have to say
watching the training there was a
generational divide the
older folks they're sort of had a
dramatic reaction to what we were doing
and what that represented and the
younger generation was very pragmatic
about it yes though this is just
something that happens in our world the
older generation was dramatic how what
do you mean I mean it's it's emotional
to watch all of these people yeah
wounds and imagine what what that would
look like in real life and the younger
people saying this is a sign of the time
I don't remember this one I was going to
the kids have grown up with it and the
grown-ups really didn't yeah it sure
makes a lot of sense it does I mean if
you if you can't prevent these things
from happening at least you can save
lives and everyone said even if this
represents the worst-case scenario if
you can save one life with these kids I
would only point out that there are a
lot of people out there who say you can
prevent this kind of thing exactly there
are steps to take you got to be ready